zeus lazarda on one with an 831 earned
run average as he makes his fourth start
to the season and
you know decision time is going to come
up fast for the athletics because if
mike fires
is quickly getting ready somebody
well something's going to have to happen
swinging ain't gonna miss so
high octane from lizardo to start the
ball game as he strikes out garber
that's a good thing to see well that
might give you an idea
fawcett he understands the situation at
hand here
he's want to come out he wants to fire
on all cylinders and as much as we have
beaten that dead horse that is fastball
location and importance
brioche's last 24-row starts
been pretty good as you can see 10 and 5
with a 386
and a one two four walks to hits then
he's pitched
hopefully that can set the tone there's
a breaking ball
foul tip hung onto by jeffers and that's
the first out of the inning
tomorrow the a's and the twins and the
sunshine at the coliseum at 12 37.
brown got a hustle and he goes into a
slide and he caught it
unbelievable what a play terrific play
in right field by seth brown takes a hit
away from rooker
and the pitch to seth is swung on a fly
ball right field going back rooker
rooker at the track
he's right to the wall and he can't make
the play it's off the wall it's in play
moreland had to wait he goes to third
kansai holds him there
as seth brown grazes the out of town
scoreboard and right field with a double
and the asf runners at second and third
with one out
almost got it out almost was caught good
backspin on a breaking ball down it in
didn't quite get it where he wanted in a
swing in this area
and right now seth he has talked about
having better rhythm at the plate and
you just see
his confidence at the plate right now
and
didn't miss by much infield in second
and third this will be jose's 37th pitch
and the 3-2 they go away strike three
called on the heater
at 94 miles an hour andrus strikes out
looking what a call there from jeffers
and a great pitch from barrios
so two outs and his third strikeout and
now it'll be machine
fastball that came back beautifully
outer half of the plate
two and two of the count and the pitch a
swing at a poplite
playable left field arise to his left he
calls he's got it
and the a's leave two in scoring
position
get well towards center loriano's got to
hustle back and he reaches out makes the
catch
i don't know may have had a little carry
on it well we've talked about the
swirling winds and the effect that we've
seen it have on the baseball and
loriano there tracking you kind of hold
your breath there got lucky little
palm ball action right at the very end
he
brings it close into the bosom and
secures it
feel the gloves i've never seen a snow
cone there
and watching the highlight of him
rounding first that's what you thought
but it turns out
hamstring gets broken down there and you
don't see him take a bad swing very
often but he just
did well that's the hard slider to the
back foot
and you're right awkward swing and
almost like
a thumbs up tipped the cap too jesus
lizardo with that pitch game one a grand
slam
shoots from the left field for a base
hit just went with the pitch
makes a big turn he's going to try for
two the throw to second base is offline
and
olson with a hustle double
he forced her eyes to make a good throw
and he did not make a good throw and
olson
is at second with nobody out
this is what you have to do against a
power arm like this with wipe out
secondary stuff
hit it where it's pitched take what the
game situation is giving you the defense
gave him the left side of the field and
we have seen matt olson oblige
more than once this is it he picks it up
and he says you know what
i got some getaway sticks let's put him
in motion so here's seth brown he
doubled off the wall and right
his first step bat left hand hitter the
pitch
swung out stroked up the middle of base
it for brown he drives in the game's
first run
waltzing home is olson one nothing
oakland
seth brown getting the chance and didn't
miss it against barrios
with a solid single through the middle
did not over swing
yeah that's the thing it's just a great
swing as barrios delivered
you know 93 on the outside corner and
seth just like you said he stayed back
inside out
a slightly angled toward left center and
just
just a great swing great approach third
rbi of the young season for him
[Music]
breaking ball hit to left and arise with
a diving catch
coming up firing and a double
great catch by arise on a sinking line
drive and he turns it into two outs
great play a line drive off of breaking
ball
he came in he timed it just right and he
had
the notion to to know that the hitter
was you know the
guy second base more than was you know
running towards home plate he made a
good throw one hopped
off the deal for the double play and you
can't ask for anything
better than next but she's been a
pitcher that's not good
bank of lights high above mark cannon in
left field just went out
starting pitcher here i'm just trying to
convince everybody hey it's okay that's
right
we can get through this outfit we'll be
just fine we've been in this situation
before and it will take a while for the
lights to go back on
and it looks like they are bringing the
players off the field
yeah some of the lights have gone on up
in that bank of light
not all of them enough maybe
enough hear that change up right in the
middle of the plate
a little pop-up machine hustling out
still hustling out eddie made a terrific
play
female marching heading into shallow
right field
sensational play great defense and this
by
machine i remember it was in the early
part of the game
made a miscue called the hit but not
this time and with seth brown coming in
machine
taking it all the way and brownie said
you take it and lizardo said i like it
a short lead by a rise here's the pitch
swung on and miss those that buy of 97.
lizardo reaching back to get his sixth
strikeout
and he says to jesus lizardo job well
done
he pitched great five in the third
innings of two hit
shutout baseball runner at second
trevino's pitch and swung on
and missed fastball away 96. perfect
pitch
just such a tough pitch to hit two away
in the 3-2 pitch strike three called
ring him up fastball outside corner
perfect pitch a rise is left at third
deepen swing and a miss he blew it right
by him
left field cannon going back kenneth
still going back
cannon leaps and he called it and that's
the ball game
his back up against the wall cannon
caught it
in the a sweep the double header